hey this is pretty exciting last year
you may recall I premiered a superhero
suit at Comic Con blew everyone away
well this year we're taken to the next
level a superhero needs his ride he
needs to get around I am going to build
a super vehicle and I'm gonna do it with
the help of these guys West Coast
Customs they are the people that
designed cars they do they've done 30
count'em 30 custom cars for Shaquille
O'Neal which is probably why he's doing
all those icy hot commercials anyway the
point is this I need a vehicle we're
gonna design it today build it taking
San Diego comic-con buddy exciting this
is the guy who runs the joint
Ryan Ryan how many years have you been
working on to customize cars all 27
years 27 years should give me a rough
estimate what is something like that's
gonna cost this guy between 50 and 75
grand I got a bit of a budget today okay
did they tell you now we're looking to
spend about $400 it's a pool this looks
dangerous yes Murph looks like with this
Smurfs struck by the car and rolled up
over the pond he looks like he's
bleeding internally and he's not gonna
make it and this one's are so super
packed it doesn't care okay tell me
Conan there's been a bank robbery you've
got to get there right away
yeah Conan there's been a bank robbery
you got to get there right away you got
to give it one more urgency sighs as a
bank robber
look there's a bank robbery going on
right now you need to get there right
away you gave it a little too much let's
take it down just see this bank robbery
you get there's a bank robbery going on
right now you need to get there still
not satisfied but okay I'll get there
geez
okay hold on hold on there's nowhere for
this foot to go shut the door this
doesn't really instill fear does it who
sits in this this is like the Kevin Hart
mobile this could be the skeletal frame
of what we do right right you know what
I like it's got no door I just jump in
the knees come up a lot yeah look at it
just the seat maybe you move to see that
right now this doesn't feel like no get
you evil doors crazy this paint job
right here fast boat kind of reminds you
of fishing it reminded me of a [ __ ]
yeah we'll go with yours yeah I've got a
better association I wish I hadn't said
[ __ ] but I did ones out so this is a
new cell that does basically takes
everything out of my mind and puts it on
paper and then this is Lorenzo to make
sure everything gets done
is it Musa Musa okay OOP said he got
Musa Musa now you got it some ideas
women want to have sex with Conan in
this car men fear this car animals want
to be hit by this car there a way we
could get a sneak peek of this dark
uniform you are gentlemen behold
[Applause]
okay don't sketch yet who said just
think all right think been sketch this
is something we should talk about yeah
yeah yeah this is an exact duplicate of
my own extremities I want to also draw
your attention gentlemen today to the
ass it is sculpted you could crack
walnuts with this you just sort of like
shape and let's not be afraid to go with
it is there any point maybe in the front
of the car where there's a desk right
here with a microphone you know I'm
saying I want to say something I know
you've built some cars for some pretty
big celebrities I'm not just another
celebrity coming in who wants a car I
know the boy from The Sopranos called
you last week and had you you know make
him a custom something okay fine he was
good don't know he's doing now but he
had his day but I'm not that kid what's
his name find out research and flash of
that Robert Tyler
let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you've got the hair you've got the
talkshow desk inside
cupholder check out that hood ornament
everybody
whiticus wine K from the back what far
back
last but not least the bold horn look at
this bold horn right here there's and
gentlemen
[Applause]
you